stop any checkmates now black is simply
playing with an extra king
white's king is too far away black's
king going on this adventure
gobbling up pawns white's pawns are
easily blockaded the black king is going
to do the work
and the black pawns are going to match
forward black's king can step across
white's knight is paralyzed stopping
black's pawn
everything's wrong with white's position
yeah no chance and there's just
there's just no way for the white king
to actually approach
that b2 pawn to release the white knight
so
that's it i mean always wesley needs to
do is just
push his pawns in the center especially
the f-pawn which is just done
well yeah he's helpless yeah liam is
paralyzed he can only move his knight
right now the white knight forced to
stop black's pawn
advance pawn there you can blockade it
but the white knight
can't do anything else simply and the
white king can't do anything we see this
opposition of the kings white's king is
trapped on the bottom row
and liam he's powerless so he resigns
wow
wesley saw making a comeback here in the
second match